sollte was geht ganz kurz und wichtig
bevor das wieder los geht also ist
eigentlich schon fertig geschnitten ich
muss jetzt noch kurz das hinzufügen
wollte mir wichtig ist ich habe nämlich
eben gesehen die liebe rebecca hat erst
dann ein ähnliches video hochgeladen
dazu würde ich gerne ganz kurz doch was
sagen und zwar das habe ich auf dem
video gesagt die video.de ist nicht von
mir sondern vom amerikanischen youtuber
habe ich auch verlinkt in der video
beschreibung des video bei mir geht es
aber nicht um essen sowie bei ihm
sondern generell hält um einkäufe was
auf kassenzettel steht aber die liebe
rebecca hat dieses video von ihm halt
eigentlich eins zu eins kopiert und ich
wollte jetzt nur nicht dass da
missverständnis aufkommen also diese
idee kommt nicht von mir trotzdem möchte
das video natürlich nicht vorenthalten
ich habe das gestern gedreht und heute
kommt von online inspirations video in
der beschreibung verlinkt let's go da
blüht drauf alter deutlich dass man das
ich glaube das ist blut hey leute was
geht ab und herzlich willkommen bei
einem neuen video
ja weil ich hoffe natürlich euch geht es
gut heute haben wir wirklich was krasses
vor eigentlich könnte ich auch schon
raus gehen
ich wollte das video einen schon längst
gemacht haben wetter war allerdings
immer schlecht heute scheint wie man
sehen kann leicht ja eigentlich schon
die sonne ja kommen wir erst mal zur
video idee und zwar kam ja mein format
oder es läuft ja auch immer noch die
person vor mir entscheidet was ich kaufe
dann wird immerhin gegenstand gekauft er
wird am ende des videos verlost was ich
vielleicht kurz mal sagen sollte also es
ging ja letztes mal um die airports
letzte mal beim apple store habe ich
hier die ärzte kaum also hier ganz neue
airports wenn ihr das video nicht
gesehen habt es ab ist in der video
schaltung verlinkt und auch am ende und
viele habe ich gefragt alex ist jetzt
mit den eher prozent gewonnen und ich
habe im video er soll gesagt ich weiß
nicht ob man irgendwann nicht zu hören
im nächsten part dazu wird das sind
aufgelöst also ich glaube als nächstes
habe ich gut ski store geplant dann hört
sich das gewünschte vom letzten mal
trotzdem machen leute was anderes und
zwar ist das wetter gut ich gehe es
gleich mal in die stadt und das ziel vom
heutigen video ist kassenzettel zu
sammeln ihr könnt es wahrscheinlich
selber jeder hat schon mal ein
kassenzettel weggeschmissen irgendwas
gekauft da was soll ich mit diesen
dingen weg damit wahrscheinlich wird zu
sein dass genau wenn ich heute
kassenzettel suche ich keine findet auf
jeden fall fahren jetzt los ich habe
richtig bock bisschen raus zu gehen ein
bisschen das wetter zu genießen paar
kassenzettel zu sammeln und dann einfach
mal schauen was ihr so finden werden
damit wir am ende in lustige ende haben
werde ich jeden kassenzettel sammeln am
ende einmal alle anschauen und das was
sich davon am sinnvollsten finde was auf
dem drauf steht also was die person die
den weg geschmissen hat gekauft hat das
ist das endprodukt von diesem video das
heißt es wird gekauft und dann haben wir
wieder ein cooles produkt was wir ja ich
denke mal wieder verlosen können so als
werde ihr am ende dann erfahren wenn ihr
sagt macht das auf jeden fall nochmal
gibt nach oben und wir sehen uns draußen
wieder
aber ich habe jetzt mal diese apple tüte
mitgenommen da kann ich nämlich alle
kassenzettel sammeln die quilt dann
bestimmt irgendwann lieber weil ich so
viele zettel finden werde genau wo ich
raus will wie die sonne wieder
also los ich hoffe ich werde erfolgreich
kassenzettel finden
also leute angekommen in der innenstadt
ich bin gerade ja schon ein bisschen
bahn gefahren und so den ein oder intel
habe ich schon gesehen jetzt leider noch
nicht so viele
jetzt halte ich hier mal ein bisschen
ausschau mal schauen was wir sie finden
also ich melde mich wenn ich den ersten
gefunden habe ok nummer eins irgendwie
komme ich mir wie bissig vor dabei um
ehrlich zu sein habe ich deswegen auch
schon die sonnenbrille auf
da sind noch nicht weniger erkennen
sagen wir mal so ich bin jetzt bestimmt
schon fünf minuten unterwegs
ich habe jetzt eine mich an öfter leute
nachklänge gefragt als dass ich einen
kassenzettel gefunden habe das kann doch
nicht sein glaub ich muss jetzt mal
richtig in die innenstadt gehen und das
lustig ist wenn man halt so ein zettel
aufhebt ich meine gut irgendwo kann ich
auch verstehen ich würde wahrscheinlich
das gleiche denken wenn irgendwer so
einen zettel vor mir auftrieb was macht
der typ da so leute auf geht's in die
innenstadt hier muss ich jetzt
eigentlich ein bisschen mehr glück haben
also das hier ist wirklich so haupt
fußgängerzone
hier ist übrigens der apple store aber
hier liegt nix also ich bin jetzt
ungefähr schon so eine halbe stunde
unterwegs zu fuß
ich habe sieben oder acht zehntel ich
bin gerade schon einmal durch die
komplette kölner innenstadt gegangen und
auf mich macht das irgendwie so ein
eindruck als hätten die gerade
aufgeräumt weil man wirklich fast
nirgendwo zettel findet das echt krass
normalerweise liegt vor jedem geschäft
zu was man wird auf jeden fall recht
aufmerksam an wasser auf dem boden liegt
ich denke mir so was zum kick ist hier
passiert so leute der nächste geht auf
jeden fall so aus sonst liegt er da
schon drei jahre
leute ich bin mittlerweile locker schon
noch bestimmt fünf kilometer gelangt
also schweren stunde unterwegs habe aber
auch schon einige gesammelt ich werde
mir das gleich mal ein plätzchen suchen
wo ich die analysieren kann
wir haben leute ich leider schon zum
zweiten mal hier lang und ihr sitzt ja
wahrscheinlich selber der boden hier ist
komplett sauber sogar sauberer als meine
schuhe
was aber auch nicht so schwer ist gerade
ein einkaufszettel oder so so leute ich
habe mir jetzt mal in etwas abgelegen
das plätzchen gesucht wo ich jetzt mal
die ganzen titel die ich gesammelt habe
auswerten kann ich hab mal nachgeguckt
ich bin jetzt über eineinhalb stunden
unterwegs gewesen
also ich bin um viertel vor drei
losgegangen jetzt haben wir 16 16 und
ich habe in der zeit hier könnt ihr
sehen 6,1 kilometer zurückgelegt 7600 23
schritte so ein paar blöde kassenzettel
naja brauche ich heute wenigstens keinen
sport mehr machen
20 stockwerke und hier haben wir alle
kassenzettel die ich gesammelt habe ich
überlegt kurz nach hause zu fahren
dass dazu machen weil hier ist mir das
irgendwie zu stressig so weit von ihrem
wohn ich nämlich gar nicht dann fahre
ich einfach nochmal ein auto nicht statt
und schlag dann zu also muss ja noch
irgendwas kaufen dann würde ich sagen
sehen wir uns zu hause wieder so heute
als ich bin jetzt mal zu mir gefahren
und ich haben schon gezeigt dass sind
alle quittungen also sind jetzt nicht so
viel ich will mal sagen so zwischen zehn
und zwanzig irgendwie ich habe bei den
meisten gar nicht geguckt was drauf
steht sondern einfach genommen
eigentlich müssen weil ein halt alle
leute die bis zum angeguckt haben
deswegen weiß ich gar nicht so genau auf
dem eigentlich 80 euro okay dann fangen
wir nur an
peek & cloppenburg sie haben eine
geschenkkarte gekauft zu zahlen 0 euro
ach so aber vielleicht hat die mit einer
geschenkkarte bezahlt dann blutrausch
alter vergeblich dass man das ich glaube
das ist blut der nächste ist von lidl
besitzt an eure 90 wird eingekauft
möhren salat spinat und lebt jemand
gesund
der ist auch extrem eklig da kann ich
eigentlich gar nichts lesen galeria
kaufhof für moment aber das steht da
schon gar nicht mehr leute der ist
komplett anders kann ich auf diesen tag
habe ich auch gefunden da steht drauf
trauerkarte elfi geld überweisen
rückgabe da ist jemand extrem altmodisch
und schreibt sich so zettel als er in
rom karstadt sport young spirit gin
tonic 147 euro das ist geil
ja was von snipes basic logo 150 euro
ist wahrscheinlich ein t shirt oder
so oder so dann muss ich mal googeln bei
kuka war noch was besseres finden hast
wenn da genusskultur jetzt den euro also
das ist unser traum play berechnung 10
euro macbook ladekabel
die haben ja ein macbook ladekabel ja
ich kann mich auch noch zur seite legen
stadtkasse köln die hat jemand zehn euro
für irgendeine urkunde ausgetreten cody
was das denn du stroum anthrazit habe
ich noch nie gehört hier kann man
absolut gar nichts mehr drauf lesen und
als das haben wir doch irgendwie so ein
anderen zettel dass das dann senden
lohse der antike aha ein spicker ganz
klar für die schule auch wenn ich dir ja
bis jetzt ja leute also ich würde sagen
dass man jetzt um 15 zettel ca jetzt
stelle ich mir die frage kaufe ich
lieber von 27
dieses t shirt oder diesen pulli der mir
sogar größte m das ist eigentlich gar
nicht mal so schlecht weil die meist
rede haben glaube ich leute ganz kurz
hier immer als beweis wie haben wir
einmal die quittung die ich gefunden
habe ich kann mich irgendwie gar nicht
erinnern wann ich dir gefunden habe ist
mir gar nicht so klar aufgefallen das
ist jetzt dass snipes quittung war ich
dachte eigentlich hat nur scheiße da
kann man es ja lesen small basic logo
rey und die haben wir dann noch einmal
das preisschild von bully da steht das
ja auch drauf also das war wirklich der
holiday gekauft wurde
und so sieht er dann aus also ich hab
halt voll gegoogelt um halt wirklich den
richtigen zu finden das ist auf jeden
fall zu 100 prozent der rudi oder jedes
macbook ladekabel von saturn ich glaube
ich entscheide mich für den rudi
deswegen wie am besten oder damit kann
eigentlich jeder etwas anfangen ich
überlege mir nochmal wir sehen uns
gleichfalls wieder beim auto nicht dass
es gleich so leute dann mal schauen ob
wir hier das teil finden
ich habe irgendwie echt lange gebraucht
um den richtigen zu finden und das ding
ist auch so ein laden zu finden man muss
das immer undercover machen weil sie uns
christen ärger und ich laufe also
verdeckte meinem handy rum
deswegen haben wir jetzt nicht die
besten aufnahmen hier leute ich glaubte
sie könnte sein
und das hier ist
so leute ich hab es war eigentlich gar
nicht mal so leicht zu finden
aber ich habe ihn gefunden leute ja mal
den rudi gefällt mir sogar persönlich
echt selber gut also dann würde ich auf
jeden fall selber tragen ich glaube
sonst eigentlich gar nichts von snipes
ich ziehe den gern mal kurz an also so
sieht er aus gefällt mir selber echt gut
hast mir auch ganz okay obwohl ich die
eigentlich über ein l trage ich würde
sagen wir machen das wie immer wir haben
gerade sogar dass insgesamt zwei
gewinnspiele am laufen
die airports und den rudi abonnent vom
kanal sein und irgendwie eine instagram
adresse oder so in die kommentare
schreiben
obwohl ich euch erreichen kann und wir
müssen mal gucken wir den who die
gewöhnlich löst das dann wahrscheinlich
beides in einem video auf ansonsten war
es echt ganz lustig hat spaß gemacht und
das war es mit einem video ich hoffe es
hat euch gefallen hat rein